i've had
too much to drink tomorrow
leave it to taylor swift to start a
viral trend poking fun at her drunk self
i'm just here to have fun on thursday
the all-too-well singer posted this clip
to tic-tac set to her song nothing new
off of her newly re-released album red
taylor's
version to drink tomorrow
that's a grammy winner singing the
lyrics i've had too much to drink and
that's taylor well
looking like she's had too much to drink
as this text flashes on screen drunk
taylor was her name mojitos were her
games so
mojito problems not champagne problems
[Music]
in the caption taylor hilariously wrote
i cringe but i miss her before prompting
phoebe bridgers who collaborated with
taylor on nothing new to take on the
challenge too oh my gosh yes phoebe
bridger's like how lucky am i of course
those picks taylor posted were from a
party she hosted back in 2019 to
celebrate the me and you need to calm
down music videos
at the time laverne cox who made a cameo
in the you need to calm down music video
posted this hilarious video from the
bash
[Music]
and taylor later joked on instagram
quote we had so much fun that drunk
taylor is trending on twitter cheers i'm
so excited but this is hardly the first
time taylor has poked fun at herself she
recently shared this tick tock from the
set of her latest music video i bet you
think about me the singer jokes the
chances of your wedding being ruined by
a psychotic x are low but never zero
yeah that's taylor looking creepy as
hell lurking in the corner
[Music]
taylor recruited her good pal blake
lively to direct that music video which
featured miles teller and his real-life
wife kelly now you're out in the world
searching for your soul as for taylor
she recently made her directorial debut
too writing and directing a short film
to accompany the 10-minute version of
her re-recorded track all too well
[Music]
e.t caught up with the songbird at the
short film's premiere and she opened up
about the experience of directing and
casting sadie sync and dylan o'brien it
was as all-consuming as writing a song
is i really directing i i felt as
fulfilled by it as i did when i craft a
song and think about every aspect of it
and it comes together and then it goes
out in the world there are so many
moving pieces um but honestly the actors
sadie and dylan they just gave
everything and i trusted them so much
because i've watched everything they've
done i've been a fan of theirs for ages
and so i knew
i knew
i had i had a feeling if you put these
two people in a room and you trust their
instincts
magical things could happen they were
electric in this i really just am so
proud of those performances and
i'm proud of how it looks and i'm proud
of how it feels to watch it and i i
really really hope the fans like it as
much as i do